last five or seven years on translating
these uh really interesting insights we
hear in model organisms from network
biology into precision therapeutics
specifically for cancer which is what my
lab works on
so the title of talk is about tyrosine
kinases and using the interaction map
that we defined to identify a new
network state that we think is exists in
lung cancer those targetable with
small molecule inhibitors of this kinase
egfr which i'll tell you about
[Music]
so my lab we're very interested in
signaling systems aspects of signaling
um in this study we're very interested
in receptors and kinases um and this
stems from our understanding about
receptors and kinases as being these
principal
sensors for outside signals in the cell
and then transmitting these into the
inside of the cell into activating
different signaling pathways this is a
very standard picture you'll see in
molecular biology of the cell or any
textbook
but
as you can expect with anything in
biology we feel that these these
pictures are are much too simplified and
they don't really reflect the complex
reality of what we see in any cell in
the body
and the way that this this um
this this
protein or this class of kinases is
typically
diagrammed is through this very simple
diagram here where you have ligand
binding on the outside of the cell which
then results in dimerization of two
receptor tyrosine kinases this results
in trans phosphorylation of the
c terminal tails of these proteins on
the inside of the cell this then serves
to recruit different adapters which then
activate various signaling pathways this
is really the dogma in the field and
this is um
kind of the way that everyone thinks
about the simplified diagram but really
this this belies is
largely complex and
newly discovered in many cases biology
complexity of the signaling
these particular proteins are under
constant control they're constantly
being recycled they're constantly being
shuttled to the cell surface they're
constantly being degraded
and they're also constantly being turned
on and off by different phosphatases
activation and then other kinases can
actually come in and activate these two
so these these proteins while we thought
they were quite simple actually exist in
this very complex ecosystem
now um
likely because of this very stereotyped
understanding of
tyrosine kinases and the way that they
signal
we know very little actually about the
uh the sort of interaction landscape of
this family of proteins so there are 90
human tyrosine kinases 58 of which are
receptor tyrosine kinases and what i've
just underlined here in these sort of
big dots here is the amount of network
knowledge that we have in public
databases around the physical
associations with these proteins and you
can see it's really um
centered around just just a handful of
these proteins
so why are we interested in this cam
this family well um as you as you may or
may not know this is a central family of
proteins involved in kinases um
sorry involved in cancer
and really these are thought to a number
of these proteins are thought to be
drivers of different types of cancers
and i'm just listed here
the ways in which they're activated and
really what the field is fixated on is
on the
activation of these kinases through
genetic genetic changes in cancer cells
for example you can have amplifications
in the kinase her2
and this is then uh fda a
breast cancer which has uh the presence
of her2 amplification is then eligible
for treatment with her2 directed
antibodies mutations in a number of
these kinases is then paired with
different small molecule inhibitors and
then also few
uh
infusions and rearrangements of these
kinases also indicated for treatment
with different types of
small molecule inhibitors as well and so
this is really the dominant form or
dominant mechanism of
oncogene activation in cancers and most
cancers i would say have some sort of
mutation in this pathway
now and in my lab we've been interested
in other ways that these kinases can
become active and
beyond just thinking about genetic
mutations
or genetic changes we started to also
think about how they could be
hyperactivated in their wild type forms
so this is not sort of point mutations
but actually just elevated levels of
these proteins and so if you look
through um
this is from the tcga studies of 10 000
or so tumor samples you can find that
across these this family of
protein kinases many of them are
one amplified in many different disease
types but they're also many of them are
overexpressed in different disease types
and so this is this kind of piqued our
interest in this family because
this suggests that there's
hyperactivation of the wild type forms
of many of these kinases not just the
small number that we've all studied
so we said about a number of years ago
in collaboration with nevin krogan at
ucsf to clone
and tag
and systematically uh affinity purify
all 90 human tyrosine kinases and this
was done in heck 293 cells with a sort
of a large number of replicates
consisting of over 400 atms experiments
and so putting these data together
there we go
we we obtained
mostly uniform and sort of unbiased
survey of the interact the physical
interactions of all all kindnesses in
this family
so um what do we use this for so um so
first we took the data and as as is the
as a standard in the field we compared
it with other data sets so for example
here this is looking at
our apms data scored with what we found
is the most robust scoring system
compass z
um and what we looked at is at different
thresholds of our network what is the
overlap with
protein protein interactions deposited
in irif web um that led us to think that
this sort of region was cut off about
2.5 was was a reasonable cutoff and then
similarly if we look at overlap of our
network with phospho known
phosphorylation
kinase and substrate pairs we found a
similar peak around 2.5 and so we
thought that 2.5 was a reasonable cutoff
here to take um
you know principally at this cut off
then we were able to find identify
interactions for all 90 human tyrosine
kinases which we think is something that
hasn't really been explored much in the
public databases out there there's only
only been sort of partial analysis of
this family
so uh so this is the this is the sort of
um uh sort of unbiased map that we
generated
so um
it's obviously quite a bit of data and
so we spent some time trying to figure
out what the best way to look at this
data is and what we reasoned was that if
we could identify interactions that
cluster um that the interactors
themselves are known to interact in
often input known protein complexes
then we could identify sort of key
salient features of biology that were
being perturbed by this family of
proteins
so here in these colored squares uh are
the tyrosine kinase and then here using
a sort of a very simple algorithm
looking for triangles and and combining
all these triangles where we have
interactions with apms data in red and
then blue are literature
literature-based interactions from
quorum or other
curations of different interactions in
the literature then we look for these
these triangles then we merge all these
triangles together to identify this map
that's somewhat curated but also
somewhat systematically prepared as well
and what we identified here is that a
number of these kinds kinases then
interact with known protein complexes
which was really surprising to us
specifically because most of these
connections hadn't been described for
example here i'll tell you this about a
little bit later here's two receptor
tyrosine kinases that interact with this
transcriptional elongation complex for
example here we found that sarkic is a
one of the earliest oncogenes identified
in cancer interacts with this lysosomal
atpase and the regulator complex which
contains uh mtor components as well so
these are some new connections that
piqued our interest not only because
they came up sort of in this unbiased
survey but they're also corresponding to
interactions that span multiple
components of the same protein complex
right so we can we don't think these are
sort of false positives because we can
find multiple members of the comporting
complex coming down with any single
tyrosine kinase
so this is sort of a sort of a survey of
these complexes so these are quorum
complexes that we that we pulled from
the literature and you can see that many
of these
tyrosine kinases that interact with
these complexes here's some of the more
close-up pictures and i'll tell you a
little bit about more some more of these
in a minute
so when we look at these complexes
though one thing that
really stood out to us was the fact that
many of these complexes aren't localized
for example at the plasma membrane many
of them are actually nuclear so for
example ptfe is a transcription
elongation complex which is a decidedly
nuclear complex
and many of them have other
localizations too for example on the
icon cytoskeleton
or at lysosomes for example and so that
got us thinking that indicating the
pathogenic case where these these
receptor tyrosine kinases and this in
which is what really drove our uh
interest in this in this sort of
phenomena
in in this case where we have over
expression overt over expression of
trans membrane receptors and kinases how
can it be that they actually interact
with nuclear proteins right now this
this is seemingly a mislocalization
of a very strongly uh plasma membrane
brown protein
so uh to do to try to understand if this
was actually a relevant phenomena um and
something that's worth studying further
we we started to take a look at this
human protein atlas which uses um
antibodies directed against these
particular proteins and then identifying
their localization within different
types of cancer cells and so using a
very simple guilt by association
analysis of the interactors of each of
these kinases we then predicted their
cellular localization
based on the known localization of their
interacting partners and we found that
many of them this for example the ones
shown down here
interacted with many nuclear proteins
and so they're for example enriched for
interactions with nuclear proteins and
then we asked how many of these are
actually consistent with what we find in
the human protein analysis and you can
find that many cases actually they're
they were consistent
which was surprising to us because these
are transmembrane proteins
and so for example here's one ddr1 which
is a receptor tyrosine kinase we found
it interacting with dna topoisomerases
and the tf2h complex and rna splicing
machinery these are all sort of nuclear
or nuclear proximal protein complexes
if you take uh an antibody a primary
antigun body against ddr1 and you stain
mcf7 breast cancer cells you can find
that this protein actually indeed does
have two lives it has a life right at
the plasma membrane you can see it sort
of surrounding these cells and you can
also see that it has localization uh a
nuclear localization sorry it's a little
bit kind of hard to see here but this is
um you can see this sort of dual
localization similarly with eph b6 fnb6
you can find this interacting with
chromatin remodeling proteins and then
you can see that on a and with a primary
antibody against this in a cancer cell
you can find that it's localized in the
nucleus as well and similarly with ddr2
it's ac it binds to the number of
components of the actin cytoskeleton and
in bj fiberless cells it's localized to
the actin filaments as well
so this this says to us that it's really
not that far off and that we should
potentially consider non-canonical
localizations of these proteins
particularly in cancer where they're
highly overexpressed
um
and this is um
sort of our efforts to try to understand
more about the biology the particular
complexes and the perturbation states i
won't delve into this for the sake of
time but what i will say is that we
found this interaction between flip 3
and this transcription elongation
complex ptfe and we were able to
validate that this interaction um is
does exist within cancer cells it's also
dependent on the binding of ptfe to
chromatin so if we knock pita b off of
chromatin
with a brd4 inhibitor we can actually
disrupt this interaction so normally
this interaction exists but then if we
disrupt
this binding to chromatin we cannot
knock it off and it's also functional in
terms of activating uh
the
the cdk9 component of this complex as
well
um so
so then uh armed with this sort of
information about sort of basic biology
of these complexes um then we start to
think about how can we use this uh
understanding of the network of tyrosine
kinases to enhance uh sort of treatment
of different cancers and really we
focused our efforts on lung cancer for a
variety of reasons one of which is that
tyrosine kinases and their mutation are
this is the really the poster child for
precision medicine and one where
tyrosine kinases are the dominant
drivers uh or this tyrosine kinase
pathway which is signaling through uh
tyrosine kinases then through
k-ras and b-raf and ultimately the map
kinase pathway this is a sort of central
axis of mutation in these lung cancers
now uh critically about 25 of lung
cancers have no known mutation in any
oncogenes right so this is a this is a
case where
we've done really well we have a number
of we have a number of therapeutics and
we have a number of sort of diagnostic
tools to try to diagnose these tumors
for example if a tumor presents with an
egfr mutation
and it's treated with egfr inhibitors we
see often very significant responses uh
initial responses to these egfr
inhibitors and lung cancer about a 60
response rate but however these
oncogenic oncogene negative tumors or
tumors that don't have mutations that
are currently druggable
um they don't benefit from such
precision medicine approaches and
because of the selection um for this
pathway we thought this would be a case
where the networks might be able to tell
us a little bit about what's going on
and and with our particular interest in
these opportune negative tumors
so there's
like i mentioned because of the
preponderance and mutation of this
pathway we know that there's a
tremendous selection for activation so
you can have mutations in receptor
tyrosine kinases you can have mutations
in k-ras you can have mutations in the
negative regulator of this pathway nf1
activation braf and they all sort of set
go stem in this sort of linear pathway
right so this is really strong selection
and not only is there selection for sort
of generic mutations this pathway the
different alleles are actually selected
for as well for example with egfr
there's the predominant mutations are in
xl19 and exon 21 mutations
in k-ras there's a number of different
alleles the most common being g12c but
there's a number of different alleles
even at the g12 locus and the g13 locus
and similarly with braf there's also
selection for different types of
mutations in breath so the most common
mutation in breath that you hear about
is these class 1 mutations this b600e
mutation which is commonly found in
melanomas and that's a that signals as
it's a strong kinase activating mutation
signals as a monomer but these other
mutations for example in in lung cancer
the majority or almost half of breath
mutations are actually class iii
mutations these are weak activation of
the bref kinase and they actually are
not sufficient to signal without
dimerization so there's these different
sort of allele specific types of
mutations we see in lung cancer so
there's this sort of harmony that has to
happen in a lung cancer selection of
different mutations
so we hypothesize then that this this
this sort of harmony or this sort of
balance of all these mutations and
activation of this pathway potentially
in oncogene negative cancers could
happen not through activation of this
particular kinase in by mutation or by
amplification but rather by changes in
the uh interacting partners of these
kinases but different different levels
of these particular interacting partners
could change the balance of how much
protein is for example displayed on the
cell surface or how much of this protein
is signaling or competent signal in the
cell
so just the initial test of this
hypothesis was first look for chemical
genetic interactions of these
interactors so for example for egfr we
took an egfr immune lung cancer cell
line and took the interactors and
knocked them out systematically one by
one and then asked how they alter
treatment with an egfr inhibitor or lung
cancer and what we found is when we did
this with egfr interactors alka
interactors met interactors or her2
interactors the majority of interactors
that we found were able to actually
alter the sensitivity to small molecule
inhibitors against those kinases
suggesting that there's sort of a
functional interaction there between the
interactions we found
and the presence of mutations and
activations of these oncogenes
so
so then we started to think about how
this network could be used sort of on
mass to help diagnose cancers and so
this is i think the sort of the overview
of the approach here so so here what we
did is we first took all of our network
data and also the network data that's
been published in the literature around
these kinases
and then we combined it with tumor gene
expression profiling data and found that
ident found the interactors that were
differentially expressed when we knew
that the particular kinase in this case
egfr was activated uh by mutation so
this has ended up with a subset of our
network and what we found is this
network i believe this is about 27
interactors we found that the expression
of some of these interactors was
positively linked means their expression
in tumors at baseline before treatment
was positively linked with the presence
of a known canonical activation egfr
and the expression about half of these
was negatively linked meaning they were
lower in tumors with egfr activated
mutations and so when you look across
around 400 different lung cancers this
is the expression of these network
components and then this is the presence
of the mutation in these in these lung
cancers and then this is our
classification of what we're calling the
egfr network state and so this network
score is really a quantitative score but
we can cut it off based on different
confidence intervals to say that this is
a particular a network positive an egfr
network positive tumors and one thing
you'll notice is that most of these egfr
network positive tumors are egfr mutant
which is by design
you can find that some of them are k
rasmutin which is interesting because
kras mutant lung cancer is actually
contraindicated for receiving egfr
inhibitor therapeutics right now
and then many of these tumors you can
see are gray in both meaning that they
have no known activating mutation in krs
or egfr right so there's a sort of
diversity here of different types of
tumors but you can see regardless of the
mutation status they all have
upregulation of these positive network
components and they all have down
regulation of these negative network
components so together their network
activity is high so overall 95 of egfr
canonical mutants um have this uh egfr
our network positive this is sort of by
design in the algorithm but when we
don't when we have a sort of a variant
of unknown significance in egfr about 50
of cases of those cases are easier for
our network positive so this helps us
potentially understand
uh what the function of these uh
variants of unknown significance are and
then for egfr wild type mutate lung
cancers we found about 20 of those are
network positive so the question then
becomes what's what is what is going on
here are these network positive tumors
are they actually signaling through egfr
or not
and so this is what the networks look
like in our case so for example this is
a one particular patient tumor this is
the egfr network
in the egfr mutant lung cancer and you
can see a bunch of these positive
components are up regulated for example
um alb and these other ones are up
regulated egfr itself is not upregulated
and these sort of down these negative
regulators are downregulated
in contrast it is for a wild-type tumor
with a very low network activity score
has has the flip of this network state
now down here are the more interesting
cases these are these are easier for
wild type but they have high very high
network activity
for example you can see this up
regulation of these components you can
see high expression of egf which is the
ligand free gfr and you can see high
expression of egfr itself and then sort
of no expression in the negative
components and then similarly here this
is a case where you don't have any
changes in egf or egfr but other
components of the network are activated
right so although these are wild type
tumors their
gene expression or the network state
seems to indicate that the egfr pathway
is active
so um what evidence do we have that this
is actually functional well um i think
here is probably is one of our first
indications when we look at the
phosphorylation of egfr so this is the
activation of egfr2 commonly through
dimerization
what we find is that these tumors with
higher network activity
have often higher phosphorylation of
egfr and this happens also in the cases
where egfr is wild type right these gray
cases as well
so that's suggested to us that this is
indicating tumors where egfr is
activated by phosphorylation
independent of mutation
so
to put this sort of model to the test we
we wanted to understand if if egfr was
activated in these wild-type tumors do
are these then tumors susceptible to
egfr's small molecule inhibitors
so to first study this
in a sort of a retrospective way we we
assessed a panel of 25
lung patient derived xenograft models
these mouse models of lung cancer
developed by novartis and each of these
dots indicates an in
an independent tumor from a different
patient implanted into a mouse then
treated with an egfr inhibitor in this
case erlotinib
and if the tumor grew after treatment
you would have that's these cases here
where the change the tumor doubled um
or um
double tripled or quadrupled after
treatment so these are progressive um
tumors and the things in the tumors in
green then are the ones that responded
or shrank after egfr
treatment only one of these tumors had
an egfr mutation they had a
non-canonical mutation in egfr which is
a
variant of unknown significance
and a number of these are also k-ras
mutant tumors and these are tumors where
that normally the patient counterparts
would be contraindicated from receiving
egfr inhibitors and so you can see this
correlation here where a number of
tumors did actually respond to egfr
inhibitors those tend to have higher
network activity as a control this egfr
variant amount of significance had the
highest network activity and had the
most regressive regression after
treatment
and you can see these these mice that
had these tumors that had a higher
network activity scores
before treatment they tended to live
longer because their tumors didn't grow
as much and this this sort of phenomena
is very similar to what we see in cell
lines as well so for example here this
is a panel of k-ras mutant lung cancer
cell lines so these would never again
not get treatment with egfr inhibitors
but you can see that their their um sort
of ic50 or their sensitivity to the egfr
and heavier lotinib is predicted by egfr
network activity as well
and we see we've seen this with
erlotinib and we've seen this with
another cohort with dakomindib another
egfr inhibitor produced by pfizer some
of this work was done in collaboration
with pfizer as well so um
um since i'm running out of time i just
want to sort of
um
get a couple of points across here so so
one is that how use we were trying to
understand how useful is this network
for this actual exercise like if you
just had a gene expression signature
could you find the same thing and so
what we did is we tried a number of
different supervised machine learning
approaches um we used gene expression
signatures and then a bunch of
regression based approaches and we we
assessed the same performance on the
same sort of benchmark validation
exercises that we did so the sensitivity
to erlotinib or lapatnip um the
sensitivity of these patient-drive
xenographs toward london and what we
found is actually the the network
approach is actually the only one that
was consistent across all of them and
giving roughly the same or or better
performance and so it seemed to be a
more robust measure of network
activation uh or egfr pathway activation
and one that could replicate across
three different platforms
and
just thinking about then how are these
um how these mutations generated like
why does this actually happen in these
lung cancers because you would assume
that the easiest way to activate this
pathway would be through mutation so why
would a tumor then go through the
trouble of activating this this network
if you accept the argument
well what we think is actually happening
here is that the majority of these these
tumors are actually oncogene negative so
they don't have ego they don't have any
mutation in an oxygen that we know of so
that's going to our goal of trying to
decipher what the biology of oncogene
negative tumors are but many of these
tumors actually have a mutation in nf1
which is a negative regulator of the
baptized pathway and to our surprise
many of them also had krs mutation nf1
was the most most enriched in this
cohort and so nf1 is a sort of a
negative regulator but it's also a weak
activator of the map kinase pathway
similarly the b rash mutations we see in
these tumors are enriched for class 3
mutations and the kras mutations we see
in these in these network positive
tumors are specifically seem to be
specifically g12a mutations which is
reported to be one of the weaker alleles
of keras uh through to reduce graph
binding
so
we we reasoned then based on these data
is that this is actually a dual driver
situation so in most cancers you have
one strong blazing driver of tumor
growth that's the one that we all know
about and that's what everyone's looking
for but in these particular cases what
appears to be happening is that you have
one weak driver of tumor genesis for
example nf1 mutation or class three b
ref mutation and you have a second event
which is this activation of the egfr
network and those two together are
sufficient to drive tumor genesis
um and and so for the purposes of time
what i'll show you is our
our our efforts to try to validate this
model
and so we were thinking about how we
might be able to use this approach as a
as a way to to treat these oncogenes
mostly oncogene negative but easier for
our network high tumors
and we did two prospective studies
animal studies so one is we collected a
bunch of cell lines that have these
non-canonical they're wild type and egfr
but have these mutations in nf1 or g12c
or g12a mutations or bref class 3
mutations we did confirm that treatment
with erlang was sufficient to reduce the
flux through the baptist pathway which
means that these tumors well even though
they have these mutations in these
oncogenes they still respond to egfr
inhibition at a molecular level and then
ultimately uh when you treat some of
these tumors in this case a g12c immune
tumor with egfr inhibitor you also see a
response in the tumor growth
so um the last piece of validation i'll
tell you about is this a collection of
pdx models so we work with champions
oncology to get a list of lung cancer
pdx models that were all egfr
well almost all egypt for a wild type
except for one so this is all the the
lung cancer pdx models that they have
that have gene expression data that we
could assess our network score the top
one as we'd expect is the egfr canonical
mutation that one um
has the highest network activity just as
we predict but the second highest one
here has this bref class 3 mutation just
exactly how our model would predict as
well so we took this particular tumor
model and then grew it in a mouse too
and we could see there that herlotinib
had an effect on tumor growth in this
setting as well so we think that this is
a potential way to to find identify
these tumors that have
hyperactivation in a particular tyrosine
kinase that is targetable uh but is not
really amenable through standard
next-gen sequencing approaches
so
um clinically is this actually a
feasible concept right so i mean are we
just sort of grasping at straws here
well if we look historically at egfr
inhibitors and how they were used in
lung cancer
in egfr wild type and also mutant
patients the response rate in egypt for
a wild type mutation wild type patients
was around eight percent this is
obviously not enough to advance the
development of these drugs in this
indication so for example the response
rate in each of our mutant patients
about sixty percent
but if you think about what we're what
the what our studies indicates is that a
subset of this of this egr for wild type
patients actually have what we think
network activation that lines up pretty
well with this eight percent response
rate we we estimate it's about 19
so um just to kind of conclude here the
model here is that in most lung cancers
you have a single strong driver of tumor
genesis so egfr mutation drives this
flux to the pathway this makes up about
12 percent of lung cancers but it seems
that
when you have
weak oncogene activation these
particular alleles
in krs nf1 or braf that's coincident
with activation of the egfr network
those two together combine
to drive tumor genesis and about 16 of
lung cancers
um so just to conclude here and what we
think is going on is there's this
tremendous selection for activation of
this pathway tumors will think about any
way that they can do it and one may be
in the most obvious ways through
mutation but the other obvious way could
be through
changes in alterations of interacting
partners of kianka genes
and this leads to what we think is reuse
of egfr in about up to 16 of lung
cancers and this may be a
targeting opportunity that we've missed
in the past so with that i'll take any
questions thank you
yeah
so do you really think it's about
mutation or is it without mutation in
egfr it's without mutation egfr um
i kind of went through this for the sake
of time but what we identified was
actually there was um
i skipped this and i'm sorry for that
the um we found that some particular
egfr network positive tumors do have
enriched from our enemies for certain
types of mutations um so for example
some have rb rbm10 mutation or rb1
station as well so it's not a mutation
in gfr but it's a mutation in something
else
um
yeah the way that these studies are set
up it's really like a mouse clinical
trial so for example with a patient you
never have like a vehicle control so the
way that they set this up is all these
tumors are growing at different rates
just like in the human situation and
they're treated with an egfr inhibitor
and they're just looking for progressive
disease meaning the tumors keep going
stable disease where the tumors remain
flat
or regressive disease where the tumors
are constrained from baseline so there's
no
there's not rolled into this is not an
indication of how fast the tumor is
growing uh but i think because there are
pdx's that have been propagated it's
implicit they do growth i just don't
know
applications
yeah so um that's something we're
working on um in the lab so what i can
tell you um
is what we're very interested in
understanding the exact mechanisms by
which these network components alter
egfr signaling or potentially or easier
for our trafficking or easier turnover
so there's multiple different aspects
which these components are all different
i'll change so um
there's no sort of one answer for some
of them we know that they're involved in
internalization some of them we know are
ligands exercise secreted ligands that
sort of activate egfr there's really not
one specific mechanism here we think
it's actually many mechanisms
we actually
by doing um
uh sort of non-negative matrix
factorization on this network state we
actually identified six sort of
sub-states and we think that what we're
looking at now is these six different
sub-states and we think that some they
have different biology each one of them
um
that's the slide i missed
for example there's six sub states that
we identified one of them is actually
seems to be ligand independence october
expression of egf
but another one seems to be expression
of another downstream regulated for your
speed which is a component downstream of
djfr so there seems to be at least six
different mechanisms that we can pick up
i think there's an establishment in 30
percent of all tumors look levels are
increased either
through amplification or or other
reasons did you check look or we can see
levels in your
system and see whether that affects uh
or contributes to the phenotype you see
yeah yeah mick m1c right yeah um yeah we
did look so we looked at amplifications
uh we actually looked at every
you know all these tumors have full
excellent sequencing so we looked at all
possible mutations that have been
reported and these are the ones that
we're showing that were
actually significantly enriched in any
particular
thank you